Grahame Grieve. I'm an Australian.
I began my life as a bench scientist in a clinical laboratory.
I'm in a clinical research,
jumped ship to join a vendor and become a developer,
and eventually the CTO of the laboratory systems vendor.
Spent more and more of my time doing actual serving and interoperability.
Generally, got more involved in HL7.
Went at freelancing national expert in CDI adoption,
realized that all the passwords on were wrong,
went off in FHIR,
and accidentally ended up as a FHIR product director which is what I am now,
responsible for stewarding the FHIR community and the standard
towards maturity and towards making a real difference in the healthcare industry.
It's a combination of things.
First of all, it's the right idea at the right time.
The industry, the community is really ready for
a spec that uses web technology and web principles and that's what we had.
And also, we created open community that was
very dynamic and community-led. And we did that.
We're just learning from other people who had done the same thing in other communities.
And their willingness to copy the good ideas from wherever they come
from has created a community that is excited,
and that excitement both led onto,
in the end, a really formal standards processes.
Pretty compelling combination for people.
And that's seems to be doing it so far.
Yeah, and a lot of app processes are around finding
a balance between many competing points of view with those in particular.
And so, partly, it's about being really willing to get a feedback
because there's no perfect answer to choose your engagement.
And that's the beauty of actual serving as a formal standards process that backs it,
is that people know that it will become a standard and a call to engage.
And so we have a real advantage in terms of bringing together everyone who needs to
be here or not able to just go some project that we won't have to buy attention to.
That's got some problems but it does make it really easy to engage,
and the other part is an intuitive process to
try something for feedback, get some feedback,
try something slightly different and eventually,
you'll see the community
automatically congregate around a single solution at a single point.
And so initially, things go in and there's a lot of changes.
Everybody settles around the idea,
but you can see it automatically.
People stop complaining and start working with it,
because you've let everybody circle and come to agreement organically.
And we see that person is repeating a lot
and we seem to be on a workable path to a meaningful standard.
Instead, it's a kind of tricky because you can easily
impose a standard from above - top 10 standards process.
And if you do that, you'll often get a stand that everybody says they cannot conform to.
But nobody really actually will,
because it doesn't really do what they need.
And so, you have to let standards develop bottom-up.
But if you let standards develop bottom-up only,
who knows what you'll get.
And it's an art form of balancing that two.
Often compared to a slinky dog,
the dog with a big spring between the front in the back.
Like, the back and the front can go in different directions,
but only for a little while.
They tied together and I think it's the same very
much with top-down and bottom-up standards design.
Yeah. Look, I feel as though we're half way in that.
But we get new scopes brought to us all the
time and some more scopes that I never expected to take on.
And, some of them,
the resource gets adapted to new scopes and some of them split off or added in.
And so, we don't have a formal goal in terms of that and in terms of how big,
I think more in terms of community
and adoption size rather than how big is the specification.
And I've sort of thought
that the right ballpark figure of how big the community is is a trillion dollars.
I mean, that's how much money
is being spent in the space of health care interoperability and
systems and that so the system is bounded by FHIR that will connect three FHIR.
The money all goes elsewhere,
but if you change this,
if you took FHIR away and put something else in,
then that have to re-spend all the money because that bridge is on to
a different set of ideas over a 20-year period.
That's the kind of dollars you're talking about.
And it's a lot of money and that's why it's really
important to have good governance and formal standard governance
because that's the kind of money that people are choosing to
invest somewhere around the world.
You measure it in terms of percentage of the world GDP, in fact.
It's not spent on FHIR but it's spent in the space bounded by FHIR.
Yeah, I have been surprised.
So I thought, we've consistently been running ahead of where
we thought we'd be in terms of standards adoption.
And it's pleasing for us that the work that we put in is starting to have an impact.
We're certainly just starting out.
I see standards, this is like
a river at the headquarters and the water flows down through the river,
the standards process is
a 20-year time-frame and we're sort of five years into the 20-year time frame.
And we're still mainly focused at
the top end where we've got much more adoption we expected in that time.
And so, that bodes well
for our ability to create change in the health care system which is our real goal.
The increased availability of data increases
the interest in doing stuff with the shared data in signing setup shared processes.
And there's a lot of interest in that.
And I feel as though, the fact that you can get data,
creates the expectation and desire to share processes.
And sharing processes has always been our goal, sharing data.
So what you've got data,
it's about being able to build processes on top of that.
And also the fact that there are servers,
we've always in the specification allowed for writing data back in.
And there are systems that do that out there,
that creates a competition and
the perception that you should be able to if only you had done the work,
on the other hand, it's a lot of work.
You really need to re-conceive your job to open it up that much.
And so, it's in spite of the fact that everybody wants it to happen.
It's not just flick the switch and make it happen,
you've got to do a lot of engineering,
it means move your business rules around.
It's a big work.
And so it's taking some time for the vendors to get there.
And they're not there yet,
but they're thinking about it and working on them.
So it's already happening in a lot.
It's certainly true that there's
a wide spread perception that main focus is EMR tighter access.
And there's a degree of politics to that.
There's a lot of projects that are just doing the work,
they're not making a lot of noise about it.
So for instance, the VIJ have a FHIR base project for aggregating observational data,
from the data collection devices that they're wearing.
You don't hear a lot of noise about that,
but they're using that.
There's a certain amount of politics going on in the kind of projects we do hear about.
And also, there's other countries,
the politics focus is different because there are at different stage in
the last cycle and they had different historical practices in the past.
That have meant that the politics is playing out in different parts of the ecosystem.
And so, when I look at it, there's a lot of noise about one part of it.
It's kind of happening.
We haven't really added anything to the spec,
unless there are people using it.
And people are taking up and using my space,
is the specification I think is.
I always say that the amount of interoperability you need is n_times_2,
where n is the amount that you have.
And as you get more bang for your buck,
as we can monetize more interoperability exchanges,
people start looking to expand that because they start getting
benefit for the money they're spending and much more easily.
And so they start saying, "Well,
we'll pick off different functional areas and start working on those."
And we're going to see next year
some very large consumer initiatives around health data aggregation,
and collection, and leveraging, [inaudible] accessible data.
It certainly really starting to pick up now.
And so, that will just increase the impetus towards
leveraging data sharing in new context and as I said,
setting up first new patient care processes.
So I think that's more and the politics of
the EHR position that has led to a perception that it's about patient by patient access.
Well then, that is true that our focus is mainly being on very fine grained,
high availability access to the data,
very integrated between the two ends of the conversation.
And we're certainly having a lot of discussions
now about what it looks like to use the FHIR.
Symantec's is a interoperability base,
but to do so in the presence of very large amounts of data,
many gigabytes of data.
And that comes to fruition in that way now,
we're now working with ENRC to trawl what they're calling bulk data access,
which is pretty much are in feeding the big data systems.
I think that's going to be the role of FHIR's place is allowing
people working on big data [inaudible] and on PMI and other projects like that,
to access data on bulk,
and moving into big data analysis systems.
It remains to be seen how much direct involvement in
the big data side of things we can or should bring.
So, I've sort of seen FHIR's 15 year plan.
The first five years for initiating the community,
figuring out what FHIR was and what would make it successful.
The next five years we expect it to be a principal growth phase,
where we were building out the standard,
and then final five years,
you'd be consolidating the standard and building up solutions.
We've seen the adoption vices running ahead of that initial plan,
but it seems as if the standard process will follow that overall plan.
So, in five years time from now,
I want to be saying that the community is
a really significant factor in the overall healthy ecosystem.
The standard itself is mature and starting to move towards long term maintenance.
The community I'd like to see,
the community focusing on bringing home the processes that
we've imagine building on top of the availability of sharing of data in birth in,
as a free flowing liquid entity through the system.
And that consumers, whether they're governments who pay for
health care or private insurers who pay for health care or patients they get health care,
or they are getting value for money to an improved health care and improved outcomes.
And the one thing that I expect will be a big issue
in five years time is starting to really rethink clinical processes,
because we're in a new place.
And it's clear that clinical processes and the expectations of the relationship between
the consumer and the health care providing system need to change,
and we're in a position to support a different way of providing health care.
And that's going to be an interesting and at times, challenging discussion.